bonsoir par rose merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors la
malaisie qui renvoie 1 150 conteneurs de
déchets plastiques illégaux vers leur
pays d'origine dont 1,43 d'ailleurs vers
la france notre réaction pollueur payeur
finalement c'est bien fait c'était la
bonne réplique que je pense que cela
doit être une bonne nouvelle parce que
j'ai toujours été préoccupé par le fait
que nous happe exportons nos péchés vers
des pays en développement des pays
asiatiques
il est moins cher de les traiter ou de
les abandonner et je n'aime pas cela
c'est comme sur le premier non ces
déchets et une vision que c'est loin des
yeux loin du coeur
une fois que c'est parti on n'a plus
besoin d'y penser on se décharge de
toutes nos responsabilités
je suis très heureux que ces pays
commencent à renvoyer ces matériaux ou
vers leur pays d'origine là où ils ont
été utilisés au produit nous commençons
à développer un véritable sens de nos
responsabilités alors c'est vrai qu'en
tout cas cette opération entre
guillemets si on peut appeler ça comme
ça
elle mérite peut-être pour ceux qui
l'ignoraient de connaître maintenant ce
procédé ces pays qui envoient les
déchets dans les pays d'asie du sud est
jusqu'ici commençaient dernier les
traités t-il ces déchets une fois qu'ils
reçoivent déchets jusqu'au milieu de la
loi a changé il ya une grande décision à
genève cette décision était que les un
pays pouvait mettre en place un
consentement de l'information
prioritaire il pouvait refuser ceux qui
n'avaient pas accepté explicitement de
traiter
mais l'été dernier des pays on peut dire
très bien nous recycleront 20 conteneurs
de p&t mais avant cela les conteneurs
pouvait être plein de toutes sortes de
déchets intraitable et parfois essayé de
les transformer de les recycler
d'autrefois mais abandonner tout
simplement et cela a causé des images
horribles
c'est matériaux été rejetées dans des
décharges dans la récession ou dans les
rivières
dans le même temps la france le canada a
vu les doigts de pied en éventail ceara
très bien nous savons traiter ces
déchets des qualités tribune très
différentes
depuis cette décision prise à genève
l'été dernier il ya eu un changement de
tout le système
alors en france à vous vous le disiez 1
cc déchets sur onze mille deux cents
tonnes de plastique rejeter en mer
chaque année par un autre pays 11%
s'échoue dans les fonds marins à notre
pays qui est plutôt un mauvais élève est
ce que ça veut dire que dans les pays
occidentalisés dont on fait partie on ne
sait pas du tout traités
les déchets ça paraît incroyable merci
dans le 10 mai les chiffres sont
incroyables
je souris en 1951 et à l'époque il n'y
avait quasiment pas de place sur terre
c'est un matériau depuis l'année 2009
151 jusqu'à aujourd'hui nous avons
produit ou de 315 350 mille tonnes de
plastique et très peu de ces plastiques
a été recyclé ou et le reste et bien les
scientifiques estiment que 200 millions
de tonnes de plastique se trouve dans
les océans
donc si nous continuons à envoyer ses
déchets vers des pays lointains
nous les perdons de vue si lui devons le
garder alors son ami ne jamais savoir
une impulsion pour plusieurs en cyclage
les dernières j'ai visité une usine est
appelée à quoi fils qui reprennent tous
ses filets de pêche récupérés dans la
mer et toutes sortes d'autres partis qui
n'avait comme était pas recyclés haut et
se transforme à l'étang du moulin et
c'est très recherché aujourd'hui donc
nous trouvons des solutions très
intelligente et je pense qu'en arrêtant
d'exporter nos plastique loin il reste
dans nos têtes et nous permet de trouver
de nouvelles solutions d'inventer de
nouvelles technologies pour les recycler
merci beaucoup pas la rose patron de
l'expédition national geographic
christine 6 d'avoir été avec nous en
direct ce soir